ce soir pour le 15 de France et si
certains ne seront pas devant leur écran
non je pense pas je pense que je vais
travailler d'autres ne rateraient
l'événement pour rien au monde ah oui
c'est évident c'est la Coupe du Monde
c'est un gros match et puis bah on est
tous à l'équipe de France je suis joueur
de rugby aussi donc j'ai été joie de
rugby donc
ouais je vais regarder à fond sans
problème pour ceux qui souhaitent
assister au match tout en partageant la
ferveur avec d'autres supporters il
existe quelques solutions qui laissent
envisager une bonne soirée dans ce bar
amboisien il sera possible d'assister au
match des Bleus autour d'un verre d'une
partie de pétanque de baby-foot ou de
flipper l'ambiance promet d'être au
rendez-vous disons qu'il y a une
certaine ferveur qui s'installer on a
tous en souvenir la Coupe du Monde 98
entre autres et 2018 aussi
j'ai sentiments j'ai l'impression en
tout cas que le rugby prend le même
essent le même élan globalement ouais on
a quand même pas mal de réservations
donc la ferveur va être bien présent
j'imagine je pense j'espère en tout cas
quelques pas de là un établissement
original promet lui aussi des sensations
fortes sur une place de village
reconstituée le public aura la chance de
vivre le match en immersion quand vous
avez sur un grand écran pardon et ben on
a l'impression qu'on a avec eux dans le
terrain parce que c'est tellement grand
qu'on pouvait le voir derrière moi
tourner sur sur une sorte de communauté
parce que moi je suis pas entre
guillemets un amateur du rugby mais je
commence à connaître et j'apprécie cette
fraternité qu'en réalité qui sont cet
échange et je connaissais pas avant et
je trouve super bien et j'ai dit c'est
classe c'est au-delà du sport que l'on
assiste tout pas aux duels tout le monde
y va de son pronostic et c'est un
véritable plébiscite pour le 15 de
France une belle victoire de l'équipe de
France je pense avec un 40
10 grand max pour la France oui c'est
sûr France sans souci je dirais France
quand même ils sont très bons ah oui
évidemment France je vais dire allez
27 10 un petit 60 60 à 10 quelque chose
comme ça ah ouais ouais faut marquer des
points il faut le bonus offensif donc il
faut y aller verdict dans quelques
heures le coup d'envoi sera donné à 21h